it's only been a few months since the
last system update but ps4 version 4.0
is here I'm Tony and this is your
upgraded gamespot news update the latest
software update packs some great new
features and it's 312 megabyte file size
one of these is a handy new folder
option for organizing your games and
apps and if you like to listen to
PlayStation music you no longer have to
exit your game or app to choose a song
or pause the track update 4.00 also adds
HDR support in preparation for the ps4
pro launch in November and if you're
picking one of those up you'll be glad
to know you can now transfer data over
land connections which should come in
handy when moving your stuff over to the
new console a few redesign menus trophy
changes and livestream options have also
been added downloading the system update
may make your ps4 feel new again but if
you're looking for a bigger upgrade the
$400 ps4 pro hit store shelves on
November 10th picking one up let me know
in the comments or on twitter at
chain-gun pope and for all the biggest
PlayStation news you're already in the
right place
you